[موسيقى]
متبوعة بقافلة من
سيارات الشرطة الصينية المشتبه
بها ، لا يزال الذيل يحاكي
كل منعطف لنا عبر منطقة شينجيانغ الواقعة في أقصى غرب الصين ،
نعم قد يعلمون تمامًا أنه لا بأس
بإغلاق الطرق التي تؤدي إلى
معسكرات اعتقال محتملة
ومنعنا من الاقتراب أكثر من اللازم  إلى
ما يسمى بالمواقع الحساسة ،
كيف انتهى بنا المطاف في هذه الرحلة ،
لم يكن لدينا الكثير للقيام به بشأننا
والمزيد حول من كنا نبحث عن
Cnn للبحث عن الأطفال الأويغور المفقودين
في شينجيانغ ،
وهي منطقة تزعم العديد من البلدان
بما في ذلك الولايات المتحدة
أن الصين ترتكب إبادة جماعية
ضد الأقلية المسلمة الأضعف عرقيًا ، تمزق
آلاف العائلات الآن
بسبب تصرفات الصين ، حيث
تعقبنا اثنين منهم
الآن في أديلايد أستراليا ، يعيد
ماموجان عبد الرحيم باستمرار
مقاطع الفيديو الأخيرة الوحيدة التي
لديه لابنته وابنه
الذي لم يحتجز زوجته أو
أطفالهم منذ أكثر من خمس سنوات ،
كان من بين آلاف العائلات من
شينجيانغ الذين
تمزقوا  وفقًا لتقرير جديد لمنظمة العفو الدولية
في أبريل 2017 ، بدأ الاعتقال الجماعي ،
وكواحد من أوائل
الأشخاص الذين
اعتقلوا ، تم احتجاز زوجتي أيضًا
قبل فصلهما ، كان ماموت جون
يدرس للحصول على درجة الدكتوراه في كوالالمبور ،
كانت زوجته تدرس اللغة الإنجليزية هناك.
سعيدة كعائلة ، لقد كانت أيامًا
خوالي ، لكن زوجة ماموجان فقدت جواز سفرها
أثناء تواجدها بالخارج في ماليزيا ،
أخبرها المسؤولون الصينيون أنه لتجديده
كان عليها العودة إلى شينجيانغ ،
فقد أحضرت طفلي الزوجين
الصغيرين مع تفكيرها  سيتمكنون قريبًا
من السفر
مرة أخرى ليكونوا مع زوجها ولكن ذلك كان في
أواخر عام 2015.
وتقول منظمة العفو الدولية إن الفصل القسري
للعائلات يسمح للصين بالتحكم في
السرد الذي
يحافظ على شيء ثمين لإثناء
أحبائهم خارج البلاد
عن المسؤولين الصينيين السيئين
رفضنا مرارًا وتكرارًا
مزاعم الإبادة الجماعية في شينجيانغ ،
لذلك قررنا محاولة العثور على
الأطفال المفقودين بأنفسنا
بإذن من  انتهى الوالدان من
رحلة الطيران التي تستغرق خمس ساعات أو أكثر من بكين
بطلب غريب من
طاقم الطائرة
عندما اقتربنا من مطار كاشغر
للهبوط ، كان لابد من إغلاق جميع مظلات النوافذ
دون توضيح سبب
خضوعنا لاختبار كوفيد قياسي لجميع الركاب القادمين ،
شكرًا لك على تحميل  استأجر سيارة
وتجولت دون أن يوقفنا أي شخص ، على
الرغم من أنك مثل الكثير من الصين تشاهد دائمًا
الثقافة النابضة بالحياة والمتنوعة لهذه
المنطقة ، والوجوه مختلفة أيضًا ربما ليس
ما تتوقعه في الصين
من البازار الكبير إلى وسط المدينة
المسجد الذي تجولنا فيه عبر
البلدة القديمة التي أعيد بناؤها
، بدأنا نلاحظ وجود أشخاص
يتتبعوننا ، وعادة ما يكون هناك
رجال على الهاتف ، ونوع من
الحفاظ
على مسافة اجتماعية ، كما نقول ، لكن
يبدو أنهم أرادوا معرفة من كنا
نبحث عن
هذا الفيديو الخاص محمود  كانت فتاة جون الصغيرة
بمثابة دليل حاسم بالنسبة لنا ، حيث
قمنا بمطابقة أزقة كاشغر القديمة
مع الخلفية في الفيديو
في اليوم الأول لا  لقد وصل الحظ إلى طريق مسدود آخر ،
قد يكون هذا لنجرب هذه الـ 24 ساعة
و 20000 خطوة بعد ذلك ،
شقنا طريقنا عبر
ممر أخير وفجأة
هل تعلم أن هذا الرجل يرى
والدك ابنتك وأجدادها
وأم جون وأبي
لم يكونوا يتوقعون  لكنهم قادونا
إلى منزلهم ،
أخبرتني Muhlisa أنها ستبلغ 11 عامًا
في مايو ولكن وسط
براءتها ووعيها لا يجب أن تقول
أيضًا وعندما سألناها ماذا
تريد أن تقول له إذا كان بإمكانك التحدث
معه
[موسيقى]
ليس لدي أمي معي في الوقت الحالي ،
ليس لدي والدي ، إما
أنني أريد فقط لم شملهم ،
أخبرتني
خارج الكاميرا أن جدتها تغلب عليها
الحزن
كما سألت عن والدتها وإذا كانت قد
تم إرسالها  إلى المعسكر
كم من الوقت كانت بعيدًا عنها لأنها سرعان ما
انسحبت إلى جدها
لترجمة سؤالنا من الصينية إلى
الأويغورية لأن
المعسكرات حساسة جدًا لموضوع
المناقشة
أثناء حديثهم لاحظ الغمغمات المفاجئة
في الخلفية
التي بدا أن كلمة زيارتنا قد حصلت
للمسؤولين والعودة إلى العائلة ،
مما أدى إلى إنهاء مفاجئ لزيارتنا ،
فهي تريد أن تكون العائلة معًا على ما يرام
، لكن هذا لا تريدها
أنها لا تريد أن تقول إنهم يريدون
السفر إلى الخارج ولكننا ما زلنا
نريد أن نعرف أين أمي  زوجة جون
وابنه هما العائلة التي تقول إنهم كانوا
يعيشون مع والديها في منزل
قريب
إنه مغلق من الخارج ، لذا ما لم
يرحلوا لهذا اليوم أو ذهبوا
بشكل دائم ،
سألنا الحكومة الصينية عما إذا كانت
الزوجة حاليًا  في معسكر
لم يعودوا إلينا أثناء وجودهم
على الأرض في شينجيانغ ،
كانت هناك مجموعة ثانية من الأطفال
أردنا تعقب
والديهم في إيطاليا ،
اعتقد أطفالي
أننا تخلينا عنهم ولا نهتم
بهم
بعد  إنجاب خمسة أطفال
وحمل في طفل سادس يقولون إن
السلطات أرادت إجبار الأم
على الإجهاض وإلقاء الأب
في السجن
، كانت السياسات صارمة للغاية ، وكان من
المستحيل أخذ جميع
أطفالنا معنا ،
لذلك قمنا  وطننا وأطفالنا
في حالة
يأس ، فقد تُرك الأطفال الأكبر سنًا الذين تتراوح أعمارهم الآن بين 12
و 16 عامًا مع أجدادهم
ميرشيبان وكيم يأملون
أن يكون الانفصال مؤقتًا
حتى يتمكنوا من تأمين المزيد من التأشيرات
لكنهم مروا قرابة أربع سنوات
غير قادرين على الاتصال بأطفالهم و
حصلوا على معلومات تفيد بأنه تم
القبض
على أفراد الأسرة وإرسالهم إلى المعسكرات مصممين على لم
شمل الأسرة ،
صمم ابن عمهم في كندا عرفات ، محاولة الهروب من
نصف عالم بعيدًا ،
وقد حصل آباؤهم أخيرًا على
موافقات تأشيرة من إيطاليا لأطفالهم
في يونيو 2020 عرفات.  تمكنت من
التواصل مع الأطفال ،
فهذه هي فرصتك الوحيدة إذا بقيت
حياتك ستبقى هناك بدون
أي شيء يمكننا القيام
به بمفردهم ، لقد قطعوا أكثر من
3000 ميل
أبعد من الذهاب من لوس أنجلوس إلى نيويورك
لاستعادة جوازات السفر المخفية في
نهاية المطاف.  إلى شنغهاي
عندما وصل الأطفال إلى هنا في
شنغهاي كانوا متحمسين وسعداء
لأنهم لم يفكروا أبدًا في ذلك  سوف تصل ey إلى
هذا الحد ،
لكن محاولاتهم المتكررة للحصول
على تأشيراتهم
باءت بالفشل ، كما يقول عرفات إن العديد من الفنادق
تبعد الأطفال لأنهم
أضعف من ذلك ،
فقد وجدوا أخيرًا مكانًا على
استعداد لاستقبالهم طوال الوقت الذي أسقطوا فيه
دبابيس تحديد الموقع الجغرافي ليعلم عرفات.  أنهم
بخير آخر دبوس تم إسقاطه في الرابع والعشرين من يونيو على بعد
مبانٍ قليلة من الفندق ،
هل تعرف من هم هؤلاء الأطفال
هل رأيتهم قبل أن
يشاهدهم عرفات في كندا ثم صمت
دقائق إلى ساعات إلى أيام إلى أسابيع
ثم أخبرهم مثل عماتي أنهم  قد
يكون
ميخائيل بني محتجزًا في إيطاليا ، ثم
بدأوا في البكاء
وكأنهم لا يستطيعون تصديق ذلك بعد عدة
مكالمات هاتفية ، علم أن الشرطة
قد تعقبتهم عبر شبكة المراقبة العملاقة في الصين التي
ركزت على الأطفال الأربعة ،
واكتشف عرفات لاحقًا أنه قد تم ترحيلهم.  إلى
شينجيانغ وإلقائهم في دار للأيتام في روما ،
سمع الآباء الأخبار المدمرة
عن احتجاز أطفالهم
وهم يتوسلون للمساعدة خارج
الوزارة الإيطالية  من مكتب الشؤون الخارجية
، رفضت الحكومة الإيطالية
التعليق على ما حدث
، ولم تستجب الصين أيضًا
لطلبات التعليق على قضيتي الأسرتين
بعد أن وجدت موهليسة لوالدها ،
ونأمل أن نجد أطفال أبيكيم الأربعة
لإرضاء والديهم.
تم تسليمهم قبل شروق الشمس
وهم يغادرون كاشغر لمدة ساعة أو نحو ذلك بالسيارة للوصول
إلى دار الأيتام حيث تم إرسالهم ،
هذا هو الولد الأكبر الذي يقف
أمام المبنى منذ شهر
أثناء قيادتنا للسيارة ، وشاهدنا سيارة تلو
الأخرى تتخلف عنا ،
هذا صحيح  هنا حيث التقط
الصورة بعد المرور
بدار الأيتام ، توجهنا إلى إحدى مدارس الأطفال
التي طلبنا منها رؤية الأطفال في النهاية ،
ظهر مسؤول محلي
وطلب حوالي 30 دقيقة
للعودة إلينا واستغرق الأمر أكثر من ساعتين
في الماضي ،
لكنهم لم يسمحوا لنا بالتحدث إلى
الأطفال الذين اتصلنا بهم لاحقًا مع
jacha من خلال دردشة الفيديو ،
هل تريد أن تكون معهم ، هل
تفتقدهم؟  وظللت تنظر بعيدًا عن
الكاميرا ، شخصًا ما كان يوجهه
للإجابة ،
أخبرهم أنك ترى أختك كل
يوم ، قال الصوت
إنه يتم تدريبه ، هل يمكنك إخبارنا عن
رحلتك في محاولة لم شمل
والديك في العام الماضي
عندما سألنا عن محاولة هروب شنغهاي
لقد انحرف
كثيرًا مثل Muhlisa هنا كان طفلًا آخر
مدركًا تمامًا أن الطريقة التي يتحدثون بها
وما يقولونه
يمكن أن تؤثر على من يحبونهم بعد حوالي
ثماني دقائق ، لقد أنهينا المكالمة
التي هم حرفياً هناك
ولا يمكننا رؤيتهم ،
لقد تعلمنا لاحقًا أن
تم استجواب ثلاثة من الأطفال حول محادثتنا
على الرغم من الضغط الذي
يواجهه الأطفال كل يوم في أواخر الشهر الماضي ، حتى أنهم
خاطروا بإرسال رسالة مصورة إلى
والديهم ، واصطف أربعة منهم حاملين لافتة
باللغة الصينية تقول
أبي أمي أننا نفتقدك  لمحة نادرة عن
حقيقة غير خاضعة للرقابة
مع كل ساعة تمر من وجودنا
على الأرض في
شينجيانغ ، بدا أن عدد عملاء الأمن المحتملين
يتتبعوننا
زاد الضغط على بحثنا
ولكن قبل
مغادرتنا اتصلنا بمحمود جون الجائع للحصول على أي
معلومات عن زوجته وأطفاله
، وكان يائسًا لرؤية ابنته الصغيرة ،
شاهدناه وهو يشاهدها ،
إنها كلبي هذه أمي ،
هل تعرف هذا الرجل  هو رؤية والدك ،
لقد تحدثنا إليك والدي
يرى أنها بخير حتى أنها فخورة
لأنها لا تزال تريد أن تصبح طبيبة ،
ماذا تريد أن تقول له إذا كان
بإمكانك التحدث معه
ولكن لرؤيتها تنهار إرسال
حبها  إلى والدها
حسنًا ، لا يوجد أبي مهما كان قويًا يمكنه
إخفاء هذا الألم لفترة طويلة ،
ما نوع البلد الذي يفعل هذا
بالناس للأبرياء ،
ما تشعر أنه
يفتقدني بالتأكيد
أيضًا ، من الواضح أن فتاتك الصغيرة تتأذى
لكنها تحبك  الكثير
وقد صادف
ذلك على الفور إنه أمر مروع إنه
وضع فظيع لا أستطيع حتى
وصف مشاعري الآن
سأحاول إحضارهم
هنا في أستراليا وسأبذل قصارى جهدي
وسأفعل كل ما بوسعي تحت ذلك
ntless الإصرار حزن لا يطاق لسنوات ضائعة
وأمل للعائلات أن تكون كاملة
مرة أخرى ديفيد غطاء CNN شينجيانغ الصين